New England Patriots quarterback Tom
Brady will march into New Orleans as he
can for a game against the Saints Brady
is considered by many to be the best
quarterback ever to play the game he's
chasing his sixth Superbowl ring this
season Brady's first book the tv12
method how to achieve a lifetime of
sustained peak performance is published
by Simon & Schuster a division of CBS in
this preview of our conversation for a
Sunday morning
Brady tells us he's getting better with
age is there any chance that this is
your last year no no at 39 the New
England Patriots captain became the
second oldest quarterback in NFL history
to win a Super Bowl now 40 and entering
his 18th season Brady is an expert at
beating the clock in more ways than one
but I would say I'm faster now and
quicker now then you know when I first
started playing football you're faster
at age forty then at age like eighteen
yeah I am comfortable grip the five
times Super Bowl champ gave me a little
tutorial so we're gonna get the balls
your feet and your get your left elbow
pointed at your target and then let's
see it's a good but even more difficult
than throwing like Tom Brady is eating
like him I'm gonna list some foods you
tell me yes you eat them no you don't
eat them or maybe you eat them sometimes
coffee yeah I've never tried it salt a
little bit mm-hmm sugar on occasion a
little bit dairy almost never unless
it's really good ice cream
well you cheese I don't think so no
cheese but he really does believe that
he's better at forty than eight well
it's not just her looks it yeah and it's
not just what he believes I mean the
stats you can look at actually how
quickly he runs up you know like a the
sprint and how he's playing to I mean
he's noisy chatter when you said is this
your last year that was a definitive no
yeah that's to play what five I mean but
I tell you want to play ten years if he
could yeah it's a really interesting
book and you can watch the full report
featuring Tom Brady this weekend on CBS
Sunday morning then on Monday here on
CBS this morning will go inside Brady's
method to lasting 17 football seasons
and on Tuesday we'll look back at the
quarterbacks diet which includes avocado
ice cream will drive back do you like
him